He's a complete mental victim when he covers anything to do with
Denims or Hassan. He can't see the actual situation. He's a big
fat liar. I don't know why he does it over and over again. He
just did He just doesn't avail himself of any of the facts. I
Maybe he has to start unblocking people just for the sake of
research. If that's your If that's your opinion on this, you're
either lying or you're misinformed. You got your opinion from
a lying re You're either a lying re or lying re adjacent,
>> It's on ice. Like there's a certain extent where I'm
like, "Okay, sure. I get people wanting big content creators
to like say their opinions on like important topics. I get that,
right?
But it's like if you're if you need a streamer who doesn't even
know anything about politics to tell you about politics, you
probably just need to like get off the internet. Like just stop.
Like Like hello. Like
I don't Like what? Like How am I going to I I don't know. I don't
understand how in the first place people care so much what they
say. I guess it's cuz they just have a lot of reach or influence,
but it's like why are you listening to them in the [laughter]
first place? I don't I don't know. If you Can you put a one in
the chat if you think that anybody who's asking for Emiru's political
opinion because they were there to be educated on politics?
Can you put a one in the chat if you think that's happening?
Can we get a re count in the chat? Not a single one coming through
in the chat. Couple threes coming through in the chat, okay.
But not a one coming through. That's obviously not what anybody
was
They're asking that because they think that there's an overlap
with Asmongold, her close personal friend, who's associated with
a whole bunch of opinions that a lot of people think are negative.
Right? That's why they're Obviously, they're not asking for her
political opinion because they expect a well-thought-out political
opinion. They're asking for a political political opinion because
it's a shortcut to saying, "Are you like aligned with
And the functional difference in the two responses is uh one
is mocking people and and saying basically lying about why they're
asking.
Right? Implying there's no good reason for them to ask.
The other one does not imply that at all. That's the functional
difference. Do you understand? We're on to the D'Angelo stream
about this.
So Denims is pulling a we're going to see in a minute. Denims
is the one who's calling her out for this. Denims is pulling
a little thing out of daddy's book, you know, Hasan Piker's playbook.
Uh we need to get these apolitical gaming or cos play con content
creators and put them in a position where they have to talk about
hot-button political issues that they've clearly not researched
at any length or whatever whatsoever. And we need to put them
in a position where they're going to say something either in
our favor that we can promote or something extremely uneducated
and stupid so we can farm them for content and pretend they're
>> Is this really If you're if you need a streamer who
doesn't even know anything about politics to tell you about politics,
you probably just need to like This is literally a base take.
If you need to go ask a random streamer like Mutahar what his
take is on any world issue, you're probably you're probably clip
farming or you're re you're absolutely
and you're literally a parasite to whatever community that you
actually take part in. Like just Okay, except literally that's
not what happened here. Literally it was her mod that asked.
Which is funny that it was her mod that asked and then she [__]
on people for asking. Like what what the [__] is
happening? Actually you're just totally wrong. You just need
to get off the internet if you're if you're interested in my
opinion. Just stop.
Like hello? Like
I don't Like what? Like How am I going to I don't know. Get help.
Like even like >> Hey, I love that Mutahar guy is here.
I don't know. dance so free
Um can you talk about Palestine? Okay, they talked about Palestine.
All eyes on, get them right now. Uh-oh, they didn't say the exact
He's like haunted, totally haunted by Israel-Palestine.
Like he brings it up multiple times.
He's just totally haunted by it.
Like I
I don't know how you do all the signaling on Palestine when like
pretty objectively all of the people who minimized the conflict,
who minimized the death that was happening, spent hours and hours
and hours and hours of their content consistently minimizing
what was going on, were wrong.
I I don't know how you sit Don't you feel like a totally disingenuous
F-slur signaling on this now? Like oh, all these people care
about Israel. It's like well, all the people who cared about
Israel, who cared about the issue, who were saying like Israel's
like all these people and it's a huge problem, right? All of
those people were far more correct in their assertions. I don't
understand how you go back and you still like try to go back
to the well on this. This is something you only do if you're
like totally insulated, right? You don't like you don't go and
try to grab new people from anywhere.
It's it's very goofy to me, man.
Uh words that we wanted in the order of which we requested. Take
their sponsors immediately I yeah, I'm just tired of it. I'm
so tired of it. You political content creators sit here and cry
all day because your viewership is kind of stagnating and the
whatever issue you're talking about is towards the end of its
lifespan. So now you have to go bother a bunch of people who
do actual like other [__] and have other topics to
talk about. Are they stagnating? I don't know if those guys are
I thought um I thought a lot of those lefties were actually growing.
I thought a lot of those lefties actually had bigger audiences.
I think we're in the middle of like kind of a lefty resur- resurgence.
Are we not? I could have sworn like maybe not Mike or Denims.
I don't know about Mike and Denims specifically,
but some of the smaller lefty creators have like doubled their
audiences in the past year and a half. Just to try to grow your
own show. Obviously, I don't like dislike any of the political
streamers except for like some of like the really bad ones like
I don't like them. But it's like
I don't understand how in the first place people
care so much what they say. I guess it's cuz they just have a
lot of reach. But Nick, I
good person or else I will have to cancel the whole thing. >> you
ever see anybody tweet some [__] like this at a content
creator you're watching, just start peppering them with responses
being like what are your thoughts on insert in one game drama
here. What are your thoughts on the Bowblax allegations? What
are your thoughts on the new Turkey Tom
If you see somebody talking about politics, you should bring
up something irrelevant, okay?
some stuff. Again, chatters didn't bring this up. Emmy's mod
brought it up to take a shot at Hasan. That's what makes all
the way the way both Asmongold and Nick have set this up from
the beginning is totally disingenuous, right? They're They're
He Nicholas is so mentally
by the Israel-Palestine question that he immediately inserted
his experience where people ask him about that, okay? Instead
of actually identifying any facts from this drama specifically.
Like it is literally her mod that brought it up as a shot at
Hasan. It wasn't somebody going to her chat to bring it up, right?
And then people talked about it on Twitter.
I don't know why you have to bring your like mental trauma into
this, okay? Are you good? Jesus Christ, man. >> And like
what that what does that matter? It's like well, I don't know,
dude. If you're going to go ask a bunch of irrelevant questions,
that's the response that you should be getting. Why are you listening
to them in the first place? Are you Did you see the Someone who
also mods for Asmon. Yeah, sure. Marvel Rivals controversy. What
are your thoughts on the new uh
sub-botting allegation? Nicholas is trying to get people to act
like him when people are like having a conversation and he's
just like "Do you guys remember the Bowblax drama? Do you guys
remember the Marvel Rivals drama? Do you guys remember Do you
remember Do you Like he just wants people to act like him. No,
other people like listen to a conversation, they participate
in the conversation, they're capable of holding a conversation
without constantly, you know, referring to other
Why Why is he doing this? because unfortunately, that's probably
going to be talked about on my stream before
um the next Ice
or something. There we go. So,
from here, Emiru is asked her thoughts on Ice. Denims tweets
out "Racist Chud."
"Never thought I'd see the day where we'd be fence-sitting the
modern
Now, I think she tweeted this out before this as well. No?
Hadn't she tweeted this out before this as well, the racist Chud
picture? I'm almost positive Denims has done this more than once.
Unless I'm crazy. >> here, and it's got some probably some
inflated bought in 13,000 likes like every tweet these days that
goes viral. It's probably somewhere closer to like 2 to 3,000,
but this is 13,000 on Twitter that you can see right now in the
bot-infested site.
So, we took the hey, "If you need to go [__] ask
a streamer like me what your what my position on Ice is, uh maybe
you should just like go off the internet take." And that means
she's pro-Ice
uh 100%.
She
doesn't mean that at all. You just disagree with what Denims
said She's racist as well. She's racist and she's a a right-wing
streamer. Now, why do you think that Denims had this
Let's see.
I did see this making the rounds. This was crazy.
She saw this making the rounds.
Emiru is friends with Ice before he text but she thinks he thinks
his clients' lawsuits are
This is crazy.
I swear, sometimes they just attack people harder for not even
having an opinion, not even just neutral, not having an opinion,
than the people that >> don't No, I see what's happening
here. I forgot There's just a lot of people who didn't like the
response for different reasons. That's the funny thing. That's
like that tends to be how a lot of things go viral. I've explained
this already, right? It's like when you can have very disparate
responses, very different um responses to the same question,
and feel strongly about it in different ways. I do think that
stuff tends to go viral a lot better. Uh no, Emiru's not one
of the good abuse survivors, so we don't use we don't mention
that. You know, there's good and bad abuse survivors. She's one
of the bad ones, so we That's fine. She uh mentioned something
about Ethan Klein
It's not related to Emmy's abuse.
It's not related to Emmy
getting assaulted at TwitchCon, or her relationship with Mizkif.
It's not that. It's not related Klein's lawsuit, and why you
shouldn't steal content. So, now Denim She responded fine. I
mean, you could say that. But, I obviously had an issue with
her response and that it was like
just like uh intellectually bankrupt, totally intellectually
bankrupt, just totally response.
She didn't respond fine. The only way you could say she responded
fine is if you lie about what she said.
She just said she doesn't like to comment on this stuff cuz she
doesn't know. That's not what she said. You're a lying if you
say that. If that's your If that's your opinion on this, you're
either lying or you're misinformed. You got your opinion from
a You're either a lying or lying adjacent, okay? is like cheering
on the death of of Emiru. Yeah. Isn't that interesting? making
the rounds. This was crazy.
Emiru's friends with Asmongold, Lacari, Tectone, plus she thinks
Ethan Klein's lawsuits are justified.
This is crazy. 28,000 likes, 700,000
>> Wow, this is crazy, guys. Look at this crazy botted
tweet right here. That's where the botting stuff comes from.
It's like
Cuz here's the thing with the botted
I think this might happen because it's probably a good way to
build up reputation on bots that you find tweets that are going
viral and then you comment and like stuff on those tweets,
So when tweets go viral or when they start going viral, they
start going like mega viral because people get in on it including
like real amplification, real people getting in on it. A tons
of real people got in on this discourse, right?
But I I think probably if there's a botted element, it might
be like just in the bot makers interest so they could bot other
stuff. I don't think this is like Like I think this is a legitimate
thing that did get upvoted a lot. Racist Chad, this is a crazy
>> believe that there's 28,000 likes Uh Red Pill Curry,
you just didn't engage with what I said. Again.
Red Pill Curry, what do you think her response was?
Just explain to me what you think her response was.
Okay? And then we can have a further conversation on this. You
can hop in the Discord if you like. >> on this tweet
and there's only 400
comments. >> views. Racist Chad, this is a crazy
So I will say tides are turning on this this particular character.
Yeah, dude. It's crazy crazy. It's almost like you have some
interest in that, right? Tides are turning on this particular
character. >> Say that. Is DarkViperAU a virgin? >> say
that. >> No, I am not. Why would so many people be googling
that? My first thought seeing this was his denims going on her
Asian hate arc. Wow, dude, she needs a racist Chad caricature
for that. Yeah. So that's what's been happening. I saw this post
pop up from a person Cherry App, but the the clip had been deleted.
But if you check it out, here it is. Denims thought on why some
streamers are afraid to speak out on other streamers. I think
we've even seen this, but it got reposted recently,
>> Yeah, but I I've never really played well with others,
so it's okay. This is Wow, dude. I'm I'm okay with this, you
I would rather Another one of the another girl streamer who's
like, "Yeah, I know I don't I don't I don't I don't play well
with others."
Wonder why that is. carve my own way in the streaming space and
be my Yeah, like his audience Oh, yeah, all of his funny chatters
did abandon him. It's not the super chats are never impressive
here, okay? >> [__] carved his way in the stream
He he could never ever ever get himself a Reebon Ruben, okay?
He's He He couldn't possibly streaming space, dude. >> Never
in a million years. my own creator. Why do we lie? Why do Why
do we I will say Reebon does intimidate other people from super
chatting, from like buying TTS, okay? People are basically terrified
to buy TTS cuz they know they're not going to be as funny. So,
it is it's, you know, it's a double-edged sword here. People
People will sub all day. We get tons of support. I'm not saying
people don't TTS they they say they don't send money. People
do send money, but they send it in a way where they don't have
to say something funny cuz they know they can't measure up. So,
you know, you win some, you lose some on this front. to lie,
guys. and not feel like obligated to any other creators than
like
have to hold my tongue because I don't want to speak out on someone
cuz that's what it is. You literally do hold your tongue. We've
played the clip where you're like, "I don't want to cover Keffals.
I'd rather do the 50th episode on Piers Morgan." And it's not
because you're really even friends with Keffals, it's because
you don't want to criticize the left. for a lot of people. They're
worried that there's like an overlap in
I think
I mean, people tend to not criticize their side as much. >> creators
Like politic She's politically locked down. >> are so obsessed
with their view count that like they don't want to lose any viewers.
So, the easiest way to do that is just to never speak out negatively
on anyone ever.
Because what if you have a massive over Or it's just not their
business. I don't This is No, I mean, this is obviously true.
I You have to twist yourself into knots to disagree with this.
It's the definition of political correctness. She gets It's obviously
true. By the way, is this lately that This leads me to believe
that Denims was probably on the same page as me from the very
beginning. I kept wanting to say Emiru there. Denims was probably
on the same page as me where basically like you have somebody
who's sending a lot of their audience to you. You don't really
want You don't want to upset that audience. So, you don't say
bad things about that It's not even remotely confusing. It's
just obviously true. Um it's obviously true in politics. It's
why you call it political correctness. It's You want to be as
amorphous as possible so people can project whatever they want
onto you, right? That's Emiru's goal is to be somebody who's
just gets a bunch of, you political opinions or religious whatever
whatever opinions projected onto her. She could be whatever you
want her to be, okay? It's core business strategy. And I think
that's funny.
But I I don't know how you even disagree with this. Let's listen.
>> does anybody care what Emiru thinks of Asmongold?
If that if she's not doing trending topic content like that.
I mean, it's pretty obvious people think There's There's a couple
different cases. Some people, just like Emiru, they want to know
her opinion on everything cuz they want to know her,
They just like, "Hey, what's your opinion on this? What's your
opinion on that?" Some people suspect that she might have right-leaning
beliefs because of her friend group, right? And they don't really
like people with right-leaning beliefs. They think they're harmful.
And so, they're like, "Hey, do you have some right-leaning
That's not weird. You could say, "Oh, well, you shouldn't do
that." Well, then Emiru shouldn't do this parasocial like I'm
your online girlfriend content, right? Sorry.
Like and she knows she does this content sometimes cuz she's
literally had this conversation with Miskif about how she wants
to stop doing that kind of content. I the Not my words. I don't
watch enough of her content to make the determination. I'm going
off of her words, okay? That's yeah. >> Frank shoots tipped
thing go. Nice dry fisherman, but I won't take the bait.
Uh you did take the bait, Frank. I appreciate it though. Thank
you. Thank you. Thank you for the five. >> the [__]
does anybody care what Emiru thinks of Israel-Palestine? Like
you have to be one of the worst possible parasite parasite viewers
to even like consider to ask that question. overlap or what if
you have a little bit of
Um I don't even necessarily disagree,
but that's like a significant part of her her uh That's a significant
part of her viewer base are those kinds of viewers.
Right? Like Like you could say, "Oh well, so Nick's trying to
present this opinion." And I think this could be true
actually there's there shouldn't be any parasocial element here.
If you lean into the parasocial element, like that's bad on either
side. I do this content. We are not friends, although he does
have a Discord where you can join and and talk to him
But I I his I think his opinion he's trying to present is, "We're
not friends. You like the If you like the content, you can donate,
but we're not friends. You don't get to know things about my
private life. I'll never reveal anything like that to you, okay?
I'll never do anything like that." That's his opinion,
And he's projecting that onto Emiru, but I think there are some
there's some differences there with Emiru, okay?
I do think that large portion of her viewer base would be parasocial
to some extent. Or you're clip farming. So just never say anything
on unless it's super super super safe to go after someone. And
it's just pathetic. It's just so pathetic. This is actually a
new clip cuz I don't remember this, but I remember the title.
I did see this, Ninfu. We're going to talk about it.
Sometimes it's nice to lose some viewers. That's the other thing,
too. It's like I don't know how people can see It is nice to
lose some viewers. Like all the people that support you are probably
people that would be nicely banned from my chat. >> banned
having those types of viewers.
You're going to come up Wow. I just don't I don't get it. >> I'm
tired of everybody having to talk about politics. I've explained
this multiple times and I kind of touched on it earlier, but
the meta is when my views go down as a political streamer,
the well, like going back to the well, like we have our well
is like when there's not really anything to talk about, let's
just cover the new iDubs because why not? When you need to ex-
Mhm. uh extend a segment, why don't you just click like well,
let's just do more iDubs because people will watch it and it's
funny and I like it. But for politics streamers, when the when
when you have to go to the well to try to get a new piece of
content for the night, their go-to is let's go after some a-political
streamer. Uh and I'm not saying like a-political wink wink nudge
nudge. This just isn't even true. This was just blowing up. They
didn't
Ah.
Bro, there's tons of politics content out there right now. There's
all kinds of of politics content, right? There's all kinds. They're
not out of content. This was just something that was massive.
They're going to talk about
I do believe that he
Huh. Uh DmoneyIndustry, maybe go to the Discord. discord.gg/HasanAbi,
okay? Throw Throw it in the content links section there and maybe
we'll check it out, all right?
Dude, there's always politics content. She could easily be doing
politics content. I don't think her viewership was falling off.
Like unless I'm mistaking something. Uh hold on, I had it pulled
up here.
Yeah, her viewership had been fine. Her viewership was fine.
Hold on, last 90 days.
Like if you look at her last 90 days,
she's up 10% on viewers. Like her viewership was doing fine.
I don't know. So I I don't I reject that that it's just that
she didn't have content or something so she needed to make this
That's not true. Like some cos play streamer, some gamer person,
someone you wouldn't regularly expect. Thank you, Mauler, for
the raid. I appreciate it. And then you go and just start like
harassing them for their opinions on politics. So, you can either
go, "Oh, look." And you do an entire segment where it's like
X content creator calls out Palestine, and you can use their
name for views. Or, the alternative is you bait somebody who's
uneducated into giving an I think See, I just don't understand
how he can keep doing this.
if if Israel Palestine, if the if the Gaza question was still
where it was in
I could understand making this comparison. Maybe even like mid-2024,
I could understand making this comparison. But like it's basically
there's not a person who's informed who's like really defending
Israel's approach anymore. Like who isn't just an about like
I'm three generations deep into Jew into Israeli citizenship.
You know what I'm saying? Like there's basically nobody defending
it anymore. So, when you're like, "Oh, all these people really
mad about Israel Palestine." It's like, "Yeah, there were actually
kids dying." And the all the jokes you made where it was like,
"Oh, we shouldn't pay attention to these people. They're all
a total joke." Uh I don't know what the politics are, but it
whatever it is, these people suck. And it's like, "Well, they
were actually
Were you just about to say I was going to say I was going to
say um uh birthright like birthright citizenship, but it's Israeli
That's what I was going to say.
no no, I was going down like birthright citizenship, the the
genetic test or whatever. But they're like three generations
deep into it. So, I to me, it's just funny that you keep signaling
about Israel Palestine about how everybody who is complaining
about it was bad. But those people were like correct. Those people
were totally
Right? And he still signals at it. It's like nobody here has
been updated on the fact that like, "Yeah, actually
you were just criticizing the whole time." And then if you're
just looking at who was like right that whole time, it was those
people. Those people were in directionally correct the entire
time. uneducated take, and then you just smear them as like a
white nationalist
um because they didn't agree with you. That's like a a very common
tactic that people like Hasan use all the time. Like why the
[__] aren't random gaming Yeah, all of Nicholas'
opinions are the on this are where he's been mentally by other
people. He is a complete mental victim when he covers anything
to do with Denims or Hasan. He can't see the actual situation.
Oh, it's really unreasonable to like make these algos. Hasan
called me like a fascist. So I'm going to say that they always
do this thing. Well, which is the thing that happened to me,
which was I got called a fascist for no reason. And so all lefties
all the time call people fascist and white supremacists. It's
like no, when when people are calling Asmongold like a possible
white supremacist, maybe it has something to do possibly with
clips like this existing. Possibly. >> I think I'm going
to resolve to become a club guy in Miami. Maybe these and women
and blacks aren't so bad. But then they prove me right. My former
life of hatred and anti-Semitism IS COMPLETELY VINDICATED. I
AM DOUBLING DOWN. MORE [laughter] ANTI-SEMITISM,
MORE HATRED, MORE RACISM, MORE S-
YOU MADE ME LEAVE FROM THE CLUB? WELL, THEN, now we're going
even harder than ever. You took that away FROM ME? YEAH. I'M
KIDDING.
>> LET'S GO. MORE LET'S GO. LET'S GO. GOD. WOW.
I just like please link this. That was funny. You know, I think
I'm going to
So like
I just see when Nick's comments go this, he's just like inserting
himself and what's happened to him and he can't get over his
own trauma. So that's what's happening right now is he's just
talking about his own situation, how he was pressured to make
political statements or how people ask him about the politics
of things, right?
He's like fighting a different battle entirely while covering
this content. It's very goofy.
And it's a battle within like a prison within his own mind, okay?
>> YouTubers talking about extremely
difficult overseas political conflict.
They've been doing this for years. I just don't get it. Keep
calling it
Shockingly, did you notice how like all of the people who are
talking about how difficult it was how difficult it was to like
actually defend the actions of the Israeli establishment.
Do you notice how a bunch of those people just kind of stopped
defending it at all, stopped saying it was like really difficult
to know what was going on, stopped even saying things like, "Well,
no, we couldn't use the word genocide or
Like they've all abandoned those positions. Do you notice? I
think he did notice. He just doesn't want anybody to like go
and look at the updated opinions. And so he just signals at the
I know I meme about this as well, but >> Nick just started
insulting [laughter] me viciously on Twitter. >> Chatters
think Chatters think that the >> partake in any of the
>> Chatters choose the streamer in collaboration with anyone
like Hassan, ask the other person two questions.
Who am I in your mind that my opinion matters to you? What are
you going to do with that info?
Chatters think Chatters [clears throat] think that the chatters
choose the streamer. Nick Nick Di Oreos like um he's like one
more doubling of his audience away from being like Nick Fuentes
during super chat moments, okay? Every time
every single time Nick sorry, Nick Di Oreo gets a super chat,
he has a Nick Fuentes moment. Hold on. I'm looking for it. Give
me a second. >> this stream, the streamer is choosing.
The streamer is choosing the chatters, all right? In her whole
thing about like, "Oh, people are afraid to use like lose a bunch
of viewers." She immediately starts pandering directly towards
her own viewers, which is very funny. I also noticed this part
here. This thing got by LSF. I'm not really sure why the actual
video did, but then I clicked on this right here. OP, you need
to get some serious help. And it takes you to a Reddit page where
you can go look at like, oh,
oh, wait, this this person has spent several months spamming
random posts about like Emiru and stalkers.
Emiru explains why she put her hand in front of a gun barrel.
Asmongold's
>> does his lamaphobia is not real. Emiru talks out about
hanging out with Asmongold on her birthday.
And called this Squala Guatemala. What is this?
Yeah, like this person is just like a
All have zero upvotes.
Yeah. This person yeah.
So, this person has been getting a yeah, Emiru responds responds
He's like trying so hard to ignore that super chat. That's [__]
funny. Gloria
He's just talking over it. It interrupts him a couple times.
This is straight up dog.
Yeah, like this person is just like a
All have zero upvotes.
Yeah. This person yeah.
So, this person has been getting a yeah, Emiru responds to recent
hate towards her. Like they've been posting like crazy anti-Emiru
for a while.
And then finally I'm like, well guys, okay, I'm going to go to
my room. It's it's been great. And then Esfand's like, okay,
okay. And so him and like everyone else who's still there starts
to get up. And then suddenly [laughter] Nicholas you Thank you.
about this last night. And after watching Nick's stream, I'm
kind of [__] blackpilled on this
I I despise people like her. I just don't want to talk about
X subject. You just don't want to talk about it because you don't
want to talk about any
Type of people who just burns that straw man they to the ground.
>> Thank you.
I need to find this FIND THIS CLIP NOW. IT'S SO RELEVANT.
So guys, what's going on over in Guatemala? And Asmongold's like
>> they stay for another like hour. What are the comments
on this? There's 100 185 comments with zero upvotes. What a blessing
to be this stupid. Stupid and rich, stupid and poor is pretty
bad. Interesting post history, very LSF 1%.
She's a shitty person for hanging out with Asmin. The people
you hang out with are a reflection of you. Uh, [__]
off.
Nick believes that, by the way. Nick believes that or he would
hang out with all of his old friends.
You know what I'm saying? Nick is the guy who has to like get
rid of his friends who who built a reputation apparently on being
the one who all of his old friends cuz they were, you know, painful.
They were hurting his image. Right? Right? Hanging out with Asmin.
The people you hang out with are a reflection of you. Uh,
Damn her and Miz were made for No, Nick believes the fact the
idea that your friends are a reflection on you. each other. Don't
piss off Asmin now. Did Bonnie call it Guatemala and Emiru what
she said or did Emmy retell the story false and she called it
Guatemala cuz Bonnie called it Venezuela?
Like I I just I don't even know what they're talking about. That's
the funny part is I'm looking at this right now.
I don't know what's happening in either. Like have we Have I
been forced to learn about Venezuela and I'm just forgetting?
Asmin's like He doesn't know about
Bro, that's that's crazy to me that you could not see any of
the memes from the Venezuela stuff. You didn't see that Maduro
picture?
And then they stay for another like hour. Actually, I browse
r/all all day and I watch the Hasan [__] stream.
So, I'm totally informed on what this is. And if you don't, you're
Yeah, I don't know.
So, it's just a bunch of like woke scolding Emiru for no reason,
which is
>> Denims lashes out at Emiru because the the latter apparently
supports Ethan's lawsuits against her, which is my opinion on
the subject. That's why I think this is happening, to be clear.
This is an epitome of delusional. Oh my [__] god.
Is Is it really lashing out if nobody hears you? Oh. I just Like
I can't imagine knowing every having like biographical knowledge
of iDubbz's life and being like, I need to see what Anisa texted
to some other
6 years ago so I can report on that on my stream. Versus, oh,
like we did a We did like a military reaction in another country
and it was like tremendously successful. Oh, I should look at
that. I just feel like, you know, 30 minutes a 30-minute YouTube
video one time.
I can't imagine being like an adult and having zero interest.
Like just nothing. Like I don't have any interest in Canadian
politics, but I still consume Canadian politics,
right? It's like I I feel like I should be at least a little
bit informed.
I I don't find it like entertaining. It's not my interest particularly,
right? Mostly cuz American politics is so much more interesting,
but I still I still watch stuff. I still keep up.
you. I hope Ethan sues her into oblivion. Why does your hair
look like that? Is it a wig? For lawsuit who's recently joined
us would be the first to tell you, uh it's not out of the blue.
This was expected. People have been waiting for this to happen
for years.
Wait, what? >> what Denim said that she was going to do
when people told Denim sues by making a reaction video, which
is basic common sense.
Try not to be mean about her hair.
Didn't Emiru just say it uh it wasn't surprising the lawsuits
happened? Well, yeah, cuz it's not surprising that Denim's got
caught doing what Denim said that she was going to do when people
told She didn't say she was going to do She didn't say that.
She didn't do a malicious lie, obvious lie. Right? Denim did
not before this stream say, "I'm doing this to take away views
from Ethan Klein cuz I hate Ethan Klein." That's just a lie.
That's an objective lie.
She did not say that. A chatter said, "Hey, are you going to
stream this cuz I don't want to give that a view?" And she said,
"Yeah, we're going to stream it. It's coming out right away.
We're going to stream it, I think." Right?
Then she should win no problem on that? No, you idiot Cringle
Kanesh. THAT HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH WHETHER OR NOT SHE INFRINGED
ON THE COPYRIGHT.
Even if she said that, THAT WOULD HAVE NOTHING to do with it.
That is It is A STRICT LIABILITY CASE. IT'S A STRICT LIABILITY
infringement case, okay? It's It's strict liability.
So, why am I getting up? Because they're
Are you serious?
Nicholas just brought it up and lied. Sorry, because Nicholas
did. Because Nicholas lied. Obviously.
Sorry. I'm Okay, I I peeked. It's fine. I'm not I'm not actually
angry. I'm just like I'm performative right now, okay? It's uh
It's just No, dude. That wasn't even loud. I was way louder last
night. Okay, but what I'm saying is I also might have this turned
up in OBS. Oh, no, I don't. We're good. So,
what I'm saying is he's just lying here. He's like objectively
lying to his
And I called that out as a lie. And you're like, "Well, then
she should win." No, it has nothing to do with the case. I'm
just pointing out the lie. He has presented the lie. Other people
have presented the lie as material. It's not material at all.
But it's It's also a Even if it were material, you're lying afterwards
after she does the reaction cuz he just said before she said
something, right? After she says, "Well, if you enjoyed not giving
that a like or enjoyed not giving that a view, you could give
me a sub." But it's after. It's not forethought.
told Denim to stop doing it. Uh Denim's getting sued and the
EFP viewers who have just recently joined us would be the first
to tell you uh it's not out of the blue. This was expected. People
have been waiting for this to happen for years. She said as much
to
What? People were expecting this to happen for years?
I don't think so. I Maybe maybe in a case where it was like massive
infringement. This is just none of the things that Ethan actually
complained about, right? Denims did not do a significant YouTube
upload. She didn't do the thing that everybody else complained
about, right? She didn't do the thing that Ethan complained about
to XQC. Hey, you take my thumbnail, you take my video, and then
you just re-upload it. Which XQC did again to Ethan. Again, W
XQC just dragged his balls across Ethan's ugly face. You love
to see it. W Felix. It was like He knew he knew Ethan was never
going to risk suing him, so he just dragged his balls across
Ethan's face one more time. His balls did the worm across Ethan's
entire face.
And Ethan just sat there and took it like a good little [__]
The J. Hey guys.
Loss, who's been popping off recently that we've been showing
a bit of >> Okay. uh has >> We showed we showed this
stream earlier. It's a fine stream. >> explain more on
this controversy, so let's take a look. Hey guys, so we have
a live stream at noon today. If you want more information on
this, or if you want to check Feel free to go check out Loss's
live stream on this as well for additional context. Denims was
looking at a tweet >> Loss is the live stream lawyer. >> Fancy
was. Loss is my favorite Western lawyer. You can see her the
smile on her face, right? Might not be Western for very much
longer, it sounds like. >> Right, you can see Denims smiling.
Typically not a good thing when she is this happy. So, there
is It means you're going to get a banger clip. >> a Twitter
account, a relatively large
Twitter account. I don't use Twitter or X that much, but it is
a smaller account, and it
Emaru with >> the Eastern lawyers? Uh we don't talk about
the go East lawyer. the statement racist
>> That makes this so much better again, cuz Loss talks
about the go Loss talks about the go East lawyer and how he's
correct. You love to see it. Uh these are the people you've These
are the people Dick has now surrounded himself with. I'm sure
I'm sure he's psyched about it, okay? This chart.
Uh and then it got a lot of traction. It got a lot of views,
especially for a smaller Twitter >> This This is such a
good meme, too. Like I want to keep this template for like every
single time a streamer starts to like try to bait like any a
political content creator into talking about current thing that
people are supposed to care about, otherwise you're a bad person.
Like just >> Bait bait bait bait bait bait bait. Uh lie
lie lie lie lie lie lie. He is lying. He's a big fat liar.
I don't know why he does it over and over again. He just did
He just doesn't avail himself of any of the facts. I Maybe he
has to start unblocking people just for the sake of research.
Right? Just for the sake of knowing what's going on. You know
what I'm saying? Like he He actually is just a total He He's
just like made things up multiple times during this. Maybe unblock
some people who post [__] like this so you can be
aware of what's actually going on. You don't just make [__]
up. Oh, well, left wing's just going around and they ban people
who are talking about this. Nope. Not what happened.
Now, I don't know for sure. We should find out. Is this person
a mod in Asmongold's chat for sure? Like also? Or is it just
her chat?
Cuz I They do have one mod that overlaps. I just can't tell if
it's this mod or if it's a different mod.
We keep going. >> dropping this under it because it's so
>> Twitter account which normally gets one or two reshares,
this one has been reshared a lot. So Denims decided to comment
on it. Emma is friends with Asmongold, Lacari, Teccy Tone, plus
he thinks Ethan Klein's lawsuits are justified.
So Snarking is legal.
>> Wait, who's that? I don't know that account. Who's Snarking
is legal? Snarking is legal.
We got a Mr. Snark. Snarking is legal.
I don't even know who this guy is.
Snarking is legal.
Mr. Snark. Snarking is legal. Wow. But Danon's obviously is part
of Ethan Klein's lawsuits and again, she's going to bring attention
to this tweet because it it goes along with Oh, that that mod
is a mod for Asmongold as well. Okay. Yeah, so shared mod. I
mean, she's literally being sued by Ethan Klein. Again, this
is the funny thing about biases. We've talked It's so funny that
that person obviously if they're a mod for both. You're get I'm
guessing given the HasanAbi comment that she was trying to mock
leftists for the thing, right? She's trying to say leftists will
come and try to bait you. So, you know, hey HasanAbi, do you
want to make a comment about how bad Ice is? You know, she was
joking. Or sorry, the mod was joking about how you know, lefties
do do this. And then everybody took the joke that Emmy responded
to and responded poorly to and they're laughing about it and
everybody's like, oh, it's proof that lefties do do this. No,
it's not.
No. No, it's not. a lot about biases recently, but Puffin again
being like, yeah, look, she's not doing this, this, that and
she's supporting a lawsuit against me. It's crazy, guys. And
everyone seems to be turning on the top political streamer that
is female. >> And obviously, she's not >> sorry.
The top Oh, I I should I should chill. Guys, if you like the
content, um we we do a little thing here where if you buy kicks,
you you sub on Twitch, you sub on Kick, you can add more time
to the stream. We have I think we're four subs away from another
hour on the stream. Every $30, you know, escalating if the stream
is going long enough. And but for now, $30 buys you another hour
on the stream. So, if you want to sub, you want to donate, I
appreciate it. You can donate through Streamlabs, you can donate
through Kickbot, you can give subs on either platform. You can
give kicks on the Kick platform. I love kicks on the Kick platform.
Uh really love those, okay? But I have not chilled a single time,
and I should do that probably twice at least before we end the
stream. So, I'm doing it now. Four subs away from another hour.
Appreciate all your support, guys. And let's continue on with
the content. >> email streamer What do you like? >> say
political? I meant no, just in an actual category that matters.
All >> Like Emma Roo, who agrees with Ethan Klein, suing
her for copyright
So, here she is. Uh it's very interesting to see the comments.
Uh many of the people do not support Denims. It doesn't look
like Denims is a Compared to Emma Roo, is a >> that possibly
be? I thought there were 20,000 people who were in support of
>> Like with a very real, not botted tweet. >> figure
My favorite thing ever was when people were trying to unironically
claim that all of Kepple's ratios were real. Should be like,
"Oh, I've always wanted to ratio somebody in the account." This
was weird to me that he thinks um all of Kepple's ratios were
like were botted. Maybe some of them were, but I thought that
was like her thing where she basically people would amplify like
it was an intentional account that was like almost gimmicky to
amplify her tweets. Like she was doing gimmicks that were catching
on with like a lot of people culturally. They would like retweet
those tweets so people could like and
Like I I think that was the whole gimmick. I do think there was
real stuff
I don't think that was fake. And I know I hate Kepple's. I hate
Kepple's. I hate I've hated everything Kepple's has stood for
on the internet essentially.
But I I think that Twitter stuff was real. Or at least like it
was real enough that, you know, maybe botting after the fact
put it over the top or something, but it was definitely real
to begin with. I would get like 100,000 likes. It was like one
of the obvious one of the most obviously botted accounts in history.
And people are like, "Oh, you've owned them. You've tactically
owned them." I wonder how much money was spent from either her
or her fans to constantly bot over every single person she went
after. Nicholas, is there any proof of the botting? Yeah, as
soon as like Kepple's was no longer liked, she couldn't get any
likes on
That was a What?
Well, after she was exposed as a total grifter who didn't care
about any of the things she said she cared about, she couldn't
get likes on anything. No way. What?
That's amazing, dude.
I was I
I was playing Rivals, so I was distracted. I knew this stream
was dumb. I don't know just how many
things this guy said the entire time
he streamed.
This is This is actually dire. This is a rough stream.
He just keeps saying thing after thing right now.
Like, yeah, when she got exposed as like a total grifter who
probably stolen that money and she disappeared and went to drug
rehab as if that was going to make it so that she didn't steal
the money. Yeah, definitely Definitely that was when she couldn't
get likes on Twitter
Uh yeah. Oh, that's what she stopped buying. No, she just Nobody
liked her anymore.
And I'm not even saying she didn't buy anything ever. But it's
pretty clear to me that she had a real uh real organic engagement
behind her stuff. She's making a good amount of money streaming.
She's making real money
It wasn't fake. It wasn't like she wasn't getting anything from
streaming. She was making a lot. And that was before Kick even
existed. She was making like 10, 15 grand a month
As soon as she came back, all of a all I saw was the money was
a problem. Nothing, dude. She couldn't get any likes after that.
Kephals again, these are allegations. According Miss Kephals,
it would be a different story. But there's allegations of like
Tectone being the white knight for Amouranth when Miss Kephals
was mistreating her and so on. I'm just wondering, for a person
who can get like 50,000 likes going after any content creator
ever, why is it that her
Um okay. Did Fat The Oreo always give more pegasier
more pegasaur
to your commentary or did he get worse after he started polishing
Ethan's droopy balls?
No, he used to He could give good takes before. I'm sure he gives
good takes now. Sometimes I I
This seems to be like a very recent thing. I don't know, or maybe
I just don't watch.
I thought he was giving like good takes before on drama, like
stuff that you couldn't really disagree with all that
I don't know what happened. If it's just Maybe it's just like
one of those times where he didn't have a lot of time to prepare
for his stream. I think what used to happen, okay, is he had
a lot more he had a lot more motion, he had a lot more guys who
would collect stuff for him and give him stuff. And now it's
just like he's kind of just rolling with the punches. Maybe he's
a little less invested.
I don't know. I don't know what's causing like all the the weird
weird like off statements here. I do think there is some effect
though. What I should say what I would guess is the biggest factor
is that anytime he's been a little bit wrong, he's slowly cut
those people out who will criticize him for being wrong. And
after a while, if you no longer have any feedback mechanism whatsoever
that tells you you're wrong, you'll start being wrong a lot more
often, right? If everybody's just going to tell you you're right,
echo everything you say, never criticize you, never come after
you at all, right? Eventually you're going to start saying really
That will happen. When you only hang out with when you only surround
yourself with complete
mouth-breathing, slack-jawed
80 IQ
like Tommy C and Willie, okay? You you start to run into stuff
like this. It just starts to happen. number has got so small
so quickly. What happened, dude? I thought she had like a ton
of fans. Dude, the Wiggler Army, where did they go? very complicated
between uh Like and this is weird cuz I you'd think he'd know
about like the demon mama stuff. The What was the person's name?
Kephals had somebody who worked for her who gave away all of
her like income numbers and everything. Like like eight different
coups happened within the Kephals community that caused that
community to totally evaporate overnight. Like everybody did
coups uh coups on the Kephals community. Like there were eight
different like separations of people being like, "I hate you.
YOU YOU'VE RUINED this movement." And they all leave.
There was a DemonMama one. There was one with um somebody who's
like kind of adjacent to DemonMama.
Th- Those are the two I know about.
But it was basically like her being accused like eventually at
first it was other people accusing her and then people internally
started accusing her and she just kept cutting those people out.
Anyone who accused her of like fraud, she'd like cut them out
of her community. She threatened to dox them. And she blew her
up completely. OTK OTK has always been a very OTK is is a more
Oh, sure. And then she went after what? Then she went after Hasan
with Destiny and then she went after Ethan Klein. Or she tried
to defend Vaush. That was her like final
thing was her trying to defend Vaush on the uh Short Stack Goblin
thing. Mindfield. The everybody in OTK drama. >> You're
just waiting for the next controversy. Uh LegalMindset is part
of the Mythic Talent Agency which is Yeah, I wouldn't get involved
with those people. No siree.
You can't really interchange them. Uh but that being said, I
don't think Emiru really did anything wrong. I think uh Lacari
definitely did something wrong and his response was >> No, Emiru
gave a totally normal take. Not great. I think TechTone definitely
did something wrong. >> Jesus Christ, Lus. What the [__]
are you putting on the screen? We're back. What the [__]
is this slide, bro? >> response was >> Lus. Now,
if you guys remember earlier, Nicholas keeps trying to distance
himself from LegalMindset. He is saying that this guy this Lus
guy, he loves this Lus guy, but but LegalMindset the Mythic Talent
people, oh those guys suck. Those guys suck, man. Those guys
suck.
All right?
Now this Lus guy is going to make a hilarious point that kind
of undercuts Nick's entire you know, entire ball washing for
this guy that he's been engaging in the entire stream so far
or this entire past few Lus went crazy here. the bait that they're
having on Twitter now because of course it is, right? And then
honestly this is the LegalMindset debate, right? Apparently this
is why LegalMindset decided to the US to head to Oh my god, bro.
This is insane. LET'S GO.
LUST IS A go east enjoyer.
go. Let's
Actually, this this comparison right here of the the On the right
you have the western angloid type archetype phenotype, okay?
And on the left you have the innocent pure
Aryan Emiru, the Asian, the timid, the the demure Emiru, okay?
The submissive Emiru. Who wouldn't choose to go east for an Emiru,
guys?
This is your This is your guy, Nick. This is your guy, Nick.
This is crazy. >> Mindset decided to leave the US to head
>> South Korea. I think he mentioned he had a South >> Oh.
True. True.
Legal Mindset didn't like women with, you know, functioning brains
like peers. He needs a woman with the brain of a 6-year-old.
That is what he is attracted to. That's what all these people
are attracted to. You're a big Emmy enjoyer, okay? You're not
just there for the fact that she was better than Miskif at Super
Mario 64.
Then, okay?
Then, you are just looking for a girl who is like acting childlike,
who is this this thing you can project onto, okay? Very
very strange, very bizarre. South Korean girlfriend. I don't
know if he still [laughter] has one now that he has moved to
Dude, I love this. I actually Lust is like becoming one of my
favorite [__] YouTubers this week.
So, it's really funny. Lust is like my favorite YouTuber. Yeah,
that is why Legal Mindset went east. Yeah. Yeah, he did want
a girl. He did want an Asian girl. No more western
Only Asian girls. >> Uh the whole debate kind of stems
into
into this situation, right? I think Emiru Is Emiru half Asian?
I don't know these characters as well as you guys do, I understand.
Uh let's see. Very important question, Lust. Yes. Now, can we
get this question answered? Lust, aka Nicholas DeOrio's favorite
streamer right now, okay? You know, we don't like Chud Logic.
He He kind of He burned a bridge with Chud Logic. Lust is his
name now, okay? Lust is his number one guy. He likes this Lust
guy who's about to actually make sure that he could say that
Emiru is is the legal mindset type by confirming that she's actually
Asian. Thank you, Lust. This is very important for commentary.
It's very important for your legal analysis for commentary. >> Dude,
he's going to Google her lineage right now mid-drama. Chinese
and German. Wow, dude. Obvious reasons. >> Emiru is saying
the copyright the Ethan Klein lawsuit on denims is appropriate,
which I agree with as well. I think everyone who's looking at
it agrees with it unless they're completely like mentally stunted.
trial. He's not Uh, depends on what they mean. Uh, is it valid?
Is it like a case you could file? Yeah. Is it a case that's good
to file? Mm. Oh, obviously not. to litigation.
Is this a nice guy? Reminds me of my uncle, right? Uh,
So, if I remember correctly, this is the >> my dad who's
just a sub. Now, we are going to go past this, I think, cuz I've
got timestamps past this. Give me a
Uh, we get through the Lust video.
had an attorney. My dad worked for a $1 billion company. It's
a little different, but again, it's kind of a nice guy who wants
to settle. All right, I missed something. I jumped ahead, but
now he's saying that someone reminds Then he talks about Frogan.
Apparently, Frogan got assaulted by Ice. I I super don't care,
to be honest with >> so, I'll just put you in a position
where Oh, hold on. Go back a little bit. >> stuff. Asmongold
Asmongold says Emiru is the one that decided to end the steak
and eggs podcast and finds it ironic she's getting hate from
people she agrees with, and that's just the tactic. The tactic
is, "Well, you won't come and do the thing that I want you to
say, so I'll just put you in a position
where you're getting like harassed until you concede." >> And so,
I had a podcast with Emiru, which I mean, which I think it's
kind of it's ironic that people bring up steak and eggs as like
a point of like reference that oh, this is how we know Amouranth
is like bad whenever Emmy was the one that wanted to end the
I I Uh ICE
a Frogan, not not denim's. Frogan was assaulted apparently. >> going
to leak this, right? She's the one that wanted to not do steak
and eggs anymore because she didn't want to be involved with
the the different like controversial stuff. She didn't want to
have anything to do with it. That was one of that was a big reason.
It was the main reason, actually. That's
That's totally fair, by the way. Like I I I I was like like I
I I I was the one like she told me. I I told Teckno and that
was that was the A political content creators are either a tool
that we can use to push the message out to more people. Uh See
Noah Samsun saying guys the Ethan Klein content is free right
now. Just keep hammering him. Uh let's just throw his name in
the title so our videos get more views about the subject because
the the real thing that we're trying to push is Israel-Palestine
at the expense of at the expense of human beings who are actually
like just trying to make content on YouTube. What?
I I don't know what thing that he was personally by again that
he's talking about here. I am actually losing track. Where he
just takes the current Now he's he's started responding to like
he's started responding to actual current dramas with his own
like times he was mentally hurt. It's very bizarre. >> example
of a person that you know, actually probably agrees with you
and you're just attacking them because they won't repeat the
party line. Unfortunately, Asmongold is correct here. Uh it's
like it it's just it's insane, man. A political content creators
are either a tool that we can use to push the message out to
more people. Uh see Again, um her own moderator who brought it
up and then people just commented cuz they thought it was funny.
Her moderator that brought it up that created the situation.
See know what Samson saying, guys? The Ethan Klein content is
free right now. Just keep hammering him. Uh let's just throw
his name in the title so our videos get more Ethan Klein was
not a a political content creator. Ethan Klein explicitly sought
out doing a collaboration with Hassan to get involved in political
content, right? To do like entry-level political content. That
was the entire point of the Leftovers podcast.
Right? Ethan Klein's not an apolitical content creator. You that's
a totally
Why in the would we
also, not only that, but why would that even be a problem?
Is he actually pretending that's a problem? How often does he
have iDubbbz or Anisa? Or how often does he hammering the same
topics? Hassan, iDubbbz, Anisa. I do like okay, what what what
point are we supposed to be making here?
That didn't happen to Ethan Klein. No, what Samson saying that
is not about it happening to Ethan not about that happening to
Ethan Klein. Now, here's the real thing is is I think he's totally
mentally ready about Israel-Palestine. You hear it brought up
multiple times in this conversation, right? That's where he's
going with this. He wants to make an allusion to how all the
people who have ever complained about the Palestinian, you know,
plight, those people are all bad. He just wants to hammer that
point. That's what he's driving at narratively this entire stream,
regardless of how closely it's connected to anything.
Right? He just wants to keep driving at that, which is particularly
embarrassing because the entire reason that like maybe that was
a like an argument you could make before was because it was pretty
hard to say, you know,
we look back with 20/20 hindsight now. No, it actually was like
a like a total travesty, a total ethnic cleansing. They wiped
out the entire Gaza Strip, like all the infrastructure there.
Um tons of the people there got killed, right? So, when you look
back at it and you basically say that people were virtue signaling
or whining too much about this, you look like a complete [__]
idiot. And then he's going to say, "Well, I don't know about
the politics." Then don't talk about it. You keep you He's so
by this concept by this concept by this topic. He just keeps
bringing it up over and over and over again.
use about the subject because
Um what was the appropriate response to October 7th?
Why do you think that's a good question to ask?
Revealing your IQ by asking that question. The real thing that
we're trying to push is Israel-Palestine at the expense of at
the expense of human beings who are actually like just trying
to make content on YouTube.
Pushing Israel-Palestine at the expense of human beings who are
just trying to make content on YouTube.
Was Ethan Klein I could have sworn like maybe maybe Noa Samson
said this really early on in a way that like
maybe he said this really early on in a way that Ethan wasn't
really engaging yet. But I kind of doubt it. I kind of believe
that almost certainly Noa Samson would have said that after Ethan
had started engaging back. No?
No, he's not saying he's saying they're they're trying to push
the Israel-Palestine thing at the expense of normal people, innocent
people who are just trying to do content on YouTube, which is
Ethan Klein to him, right? Now Ethan Klein was commenting on
this stuff. He was commenting politically. It's the whole point
of Leftovers. And he was commenting on Israel-Palestine.
There was a huge blowup with him and Right? I don't know. It's
just the whole thing is is goofy as Ethan Klein is like this
in this totally innocent. He never He never hurt nobody,
He went He never hurt nobody. Ethan didn't do anything. Right.
Or you go the other way, you bait them into saying something
ignorant, you just farm them and farm them and farm Bait them
into saying something ignorant. You just farm them and farm them
and farm them. His entire stream is predicated on a lie.
His entire stream is predicated on a
Bro, I didn't know I didn't know it was this bad. I just haven't
been paying attention to Nicholas. I didn't know it was this
bad, man.
I It's her mod who asked the question.
This was information I knew last night.
There's no reason you couldn't have known this.
And by the way, anybody who wants to be informed on stuff is
blocked by him. So, there's no way he could find this out, right?
He's just He's blocked any way he has of getting signals from
other groups that he is wrong. So, this will happen again and
again and again cuz the only people who hang out with this guy
are
Who can't handle who who probably can't handle or he can't handle
being told being told he's wrong, who probably can't, you know,
risk telling him he's wrong. It's really really really unfortunate
for him. He's put himself in a box where he can't even get told
he's wrong about something before he goes live. Augie, I believe
he's distancing from I thought he was distancing from Augie.
Augie would be the exception.
But, I do think that basically where Augie goes and argues with
people, it's like we could just talk to Nick directly. Augie
basically gets feedback for Nick for Nick.
And like lets himself get, you know, basically maligned in the
process. Augie comes on the stream to like basically sit here
and be a stand-in for Nick, which sucks because Nick's too scared
to do it himself. Anyway, it's uh it's just sad. It's sad to
see. Arm them and farm
>> So, Asmongold's unfortunately for many correct on this
one.
Uh the moderation of this thread. All right. I think a lot of
people who use the cancel podcast to show that she's bad don't
even know the podcast is canceled and assume she is still doing
That's probably true. I don't even know what the cancel podcast
is, but I can believe that. Is this even He doesn't even know
what the cancel podcast is. Do you think maybe it has something
to do with the clip he just watched that's about the Steak and
Eggs podcast that was canceled because Emiru wanted it
Do you think maybe that's possible that that's the cancel podcast
in this case? I don't even know what the cancel podcast is, guys.
Who baited him into saying that? I don't know what Ice is. I
don't even know what Ice is. What is Ice? What is the Cancel
Podcast? Who baited him into making this statement so everybody
can farm him? Who did that to Nicholas?
Who did it? Oh, it was Nicholas again.
I literally just went on a 10-minute rant about how this guy's
uninformed and is making himself look like a [__]
and then he follows up. He follows up my entire rant with that
gem. Thank you, Nicholas. Thank you. >> content on YouTube.
And you know, Asmongold's unfortunately for many correct on this
one. I think a lot of people who use the Cancel Podcast to show
that she's bad don't even know the podcast is canceled and assume
she is still doing it. Oh. >> Emiru seems really passive
about making statements publicly and it keeps biting her in the
ass. What she should do, and this is actually advice,
ban them.
Even filtering those words out of the
And I'm talking about all of them. If people are coming in to
clip farm politics to post on social Again, he's just projecting
his own onto this scenario, his own mental is being projected
onto this scenario over and over again. He really hated when
people came in and asked him, "Hey, you're like criticizing this
guy, but don't you think you should know about the politics to
like inform your opinion?" And he's so eternally ruined by that
by that comment that he has to keep projecting it onto the scenario
over and over and over again.
just ban them. They're not your viewers. They don't matter. And
if they are, well, they weren't going to be here long for any
I guess anyway. Just throw them out of the chat. Who cares? By
acknowledging them at all whatsoever, all you are accomplishing
is giving them a clip to say that you have made a position that
you literally didn't say. So, I think this is literally just
a time to use the tools that you have at your disposal and purge
people who are showing up intentionally trying to one got you
into getting a clip posted to LSF. Throw them out.
You don't owe them an explanation. You didn't do anything wrong.
Some of y'all reiterate time and time again that streamers are
the dumbest people on Earth and shouldn't give any opinions and
takes on any situation whatsoever. And then when she does exactly
that, you get Yes, also given her fan base and Not what she said.
You just have to lie. You have to lie to yourself about what
she said to to defend, right?
You're saying any for If you want to know what her opinion for
any reason, you need to go outside. You're a [__]
loser if you want to know my opinion.
Nope, not true. Not required. Not Not a statement that is true.
Some communities, if she takes a strong position publicly, she
might get assaulted by some of the psychos that feel betrayed.
She already has trouble keeping out creeps at bay. I don't know
about that. I know I know about this part, but I think that's
a little much, right? If you think that others should put themselves
in the crosshairs, maybe you should lead by example, risk your
neck, then come back to preach. The um only people who Is that
mocking Charlie Kirk? Uh excuse me, Asmongold.
I have somebody you need to search out. I think What do you mean
risk your neck?
Giving your political Excuse me. >> for this or political
content creators that have something to gain or commentators
who have nothing to lose. Those are the ones who always tell
you what you should do with your platform. People who can literally
profit off of your death. This again, just projecting his own
situation onto this. Commentators comment on everything cuz they
can. Cuz that's the whole point. That's literally the job to
comment on things.
Um and he's just projecting He's just like He's trying to build
the rules. He's trying to set the rules for this like he has
for a very long time. And a lot of people aren't playing by these
rules anymore, okay? He doesn't get to set the discourse in the
way he was
All right? Uh you would have to just be a total loser to disagree
with me. Yeah, yeah, hold on. I didn't want to get to that part
yet. You'd have to be a total loser to disagree with me. You're
just like wrong if you disagree with me at all. No. No. I have
something that is not anything they've criticized here that was
my original criticism. I just threw it out like, "Hey, I just
say just say you want to make money. You don't want to offend
people. Just say that. That's fine. That's fine with me. Just
be transparent. Be like Mike. BE LIKE MIKE. JUST like the advertising
bit from the '90s. Be I think the '90s?
I don't know. I saw it in the Dream Team documentary. Be like
Mike, okay? Should lead by example, risk your neck, then come
back to preach. That sounds equally bad? Yeah. What she should
have said was, "I don't comment." If you're going to say you're
a for wanting my comment, then just be honest about why you don't
want to comment.
Okay? Don't do the thing that like, "Oh, I'm trying to help you
by letting you know that you're like probably too parasocial
online." Yeah, Emiru's really concerned about the parasociality
of her audience, right? She's really concerned about the parasociality
or the political leanings of her audience. But, either one of
those is really believable, for sure. "You guys are like a little
too parasocial. You should go outside."
Or No, actually, you guys, if you want political opinions from
online content creators, you should go outside. She's either
talking to her friend Asmongold
or
she's saying people are too parasocial in her audience, which
is what the audience is predicated on, right? Neither of those
are true. It's just the money thing. It's obviously the money
thing. And so, you have two options. Be honest or shut the [__]
up. Don't lie to me and tell me that I need to be better because
I disagree with
That's all. That's all I don't like. Don't try to manipulate
me by saying this is this would actually be healthier for you.
Don't try to manipulate me. Just say you're not going to comment
or say you want your money. Either one's fine with me. By the
way, that's my comment. That's my opinion. You can disagree with
that if you like.
But, I can give that opinion. And it's not incorrect.
Or feel free to to point out which part you think is incorrect.
The um only people who'd call you out for this are political
content creators that have something to gain or commentators
who have nothing to lose. Those are the ones who always tell
you what you should do with your platform. People who can literally
profit off of your death or chatters who are Profit off of your
death?
Bro, you can just see he drops little hints about where his mind
state is all over this stream. These people These people are
trying to profit off of my death. That's the only reason they
disagree with me cuz they're trying to profit off of my death.
They want me
Now Now Now I will say there's some There's a comment in the
chat currently that may or may not lead people in that direction,
but it is tongue-in-cheek. Okay, it is tongue-in-cheek. It's
Um have absolutely no stake in this fight uh who don't make any
money off of this who tell you how to run your channel. So
Is this a leak where he knew this? I just remember that Asmon
has been lying about a lot of these details. You can't really
take Asmon 100% when he's talking Why can't it be just be that
she's a political? Why does it have to be that she wants money?
Um cuz one I don't believe she'd hang out with Asmongold to be
a political and she has been hanging out with Asmongold a lot.
Clearly, right? I don't think she'd be a political and I I didn't
think that she was political in terms of she agreed with Asmongold.
Right? And she clearly gave her opinion here which is basically
saying she like ice. It's basically what she said on Right? We've
already got that update that she basically says ice on Twitter.
Didn't believe she was a political, didn't really believe she
Honestly, she like kind of implied it, but I didn't believe it
to begin with. Right? And
that's been revealed now. Yeah, it's not about her being a political.
She wants her channel to be a political so that she's not, you
know, so it does become like a a breeding ground for that kind
of, you know, rhetoric and she has to become extreme or something
or, you know, she slowly gets pushed in a direction. She just
wants to avoid it all. She just wants to be the Emiru channel.
It's about Emiru. Not about politics. Talking about any of this
[__] The people demanding Emiru or streamers state
their political views of the Also, the reason you want to keep
it a political is for the sake of money. I guess there's there's
some way you could say that it's she wants to keep it a political
purely because
you know, uh it's going to come it's going to be money in either
case, but you could say a little more charitably that she feels
more at peace not having to talk about these topics. And so,
while maybe she could make more money doing a political like
leaning of some kind some kind of political thing, she just wants
to not have to deal with that at all. Maybe you could argue that.
Maybe.
The same ones crying that Twitch streaming isn't gaming anymore.
I don't care about Emiru or Kacey or any of the streaming political
views. If I show up to a stream, it's probably to watch them
play video games and talk about video games. There is a dedicated
political streamer thing that you can go for the political tab.
Otherwise, let streamers do whatever and watch whatever they
want. Let's find out why this person's wrong. Politics have real-world
consequences. That's great. I wouldn't expect You know, I I don't
know. I would say I wouldn't expect random TV shows I'm watching,
but nowadays they do that.
Uh people want to know where you stand on issues that affect
people. Okay, well, get the [__] out.
I don't think I have the luxury of doing that all the time cuz
we do talk about politics on the stream, but best be known if
I was a By the way, I actually
I don't think I'd have a problem. You know, I wouldn't like make
more of a deal out of it. My opinion would remain the same, but
it's not like I'm going to continue to push Emiru. If she just
said, "Actually,
I do think you if you want my political opinion. I think like
get the [__] out of here if you want my political
opinion. [__] off." She said that, that would also
be awesome.
But she didn't have that opinion either, did she? a GTA streamer
and you came in asking me about Israel, Gaza, Venezuela,
Vietnam, your [__] would be off my stream within
seconds. You'd be gone. Holy [__] No, I think if
if you're a gaming streamer and these people are coming in asking
you about literally
get the [__] out, dude.
There are times when it's not like a one-sided thing, too. The
The biggest issue that I had We covered this a bunch of times.
Massive Emiru updates.
It's a Techtone tweet. Hold on. Never apologize to the Bob. Never
try to rationalize with those who weren't rational to begin with.
Wow. Wow, thank you, Techtone. Is that Marcus Aurelius?
Was that Did you read that in the Meditations, Techtone?
Sorry, I said the Meditations. I believe it's just Meditations,
but is that
Is that where you got that, man? Is that where you got it? Look
at this rational man. Oh, hold on. You got a Shemu tweet? Is
this a new Shemu tweet? Dead You're Techtone and the judge asks
you why they should appeal a 10-year-old protective >> can
talk. That's what people will learn Oh, hold on. Hold on. Dead
people can talk. That's what people will learn very soon. I know
everything and that's why they fear me and that's why they try
to discredit me. And once again, guys, I'm schizophrenic and
I have a gun. I'm a very dangerous man. Dead people He loves
saying I'm a very dangerous man the whole time. Yeah, this is
uh Bro, his lawyers must have just been pulling their hair out
the whole time. I have a Oh, he had a Dude, there's no way he
bought a shirt. He Did he custom make a shirt
or buy a shirt that says, "I have a gun and I and am schizophrenic"?
You think he kept that shirt? I don't know, man. This Honestly,
I think 10 years was too short. There is a chance that he goes
10 years without opting out, okay? 10 years, that's too short.
If he appeals, put it up. Up higher. More. More. More. Okay,
more.
times with Palestine in particular is if you gave any take that
wasn't 100% from the Actually true. Hold on. Actually true. Wait.
I went I went back too soon. Neither of those things are true
talk. That Both of those things are now false. Amazing.
Classic. Classic. Classic. Classic. >> river to the sea
for like a solid month. People would just do say that you're
a Zionist, say that you want to kill a bunch of children, ask
if you support Oh god, he's just going to rant about Zionists
again. Or sorry, about about anti-Zionists again. Why?
>> issue that I had, and we covered this a bunch of times
with Palestine in particular, is if you gave any take that wasn't
100% from the river to the sea for like a solid month, people
would just do say that you're a Zionist, say that you want to
kill a bunch of children, ask if you support
whatever the Like that would just happen immediately. And then
if you responded back by saying, "It's a complex issue that I'm
not read up on." They would go, "Genocide isn't complex."
And then you'd get tweets with a bunch of people coming after
you. Okay.
But like
a lot of people basically have sort of said, "No, seems kind
of genocidal now." Wouldn't The entire thing that this boils
down to is whether or not you believe there's a genocide going
on, right? That's what it boils down to. And I would say most
people I know of who were arguing that it wasn't, clearly wasn't,
you couldn't even remotely call it that. I think almost all of
those people have sort of capitulated and
"It's pretty It's pretty much a genocide now. It's pretty much
a
Like you're just You're just wrong now, and you look like it.
Just a seething
just a seething [__] baby when you keep bringing
it up as if it's like as if it's
Huh. You just look like a seething [__] baby by bringing
it up all the time, especially in not totally unrelated, but
basically unrelated dramas. You know, especially when it wasn't
brought up by other people like you keep saying. Like when it
was brought up by Hermod. You just look goofy. But like as if
he were vindicated. Yeah, he's not vindicated. He's the opposite
of vindicated, okay? Like the people he was criticizing are
It is a complicated situation. It's always been a complicated
situation.
That This is This is the problem with having no political concern
at all and then tying your commentary to some political topic
is he's never cared to go and update any of his opinions, so
he's got old opinions that make him look uninformed and he'll
keep leaning on them over and over and over again and looking
dumber and dumber and dumber,
>> More dumb and more dumb and more dumb, but he'll do
it. That's when you realize the person who's going after you
isn't even informed on the issue.
They're just repeating something
Would it be bad to go after somebody in their statements on Israel-Palestine
without being informed on the issue? Hmm.
Wow, what a weird What an awesome criticism to make. >> said
to them. None of these people know what they're talking about,
man. They can't argue these talking points. They're just checking
your privilege. They're woke scolding you. These guys who are
asking you, "Um, what do you think about Palestine?" They became
I don't I don't know where you become like where you think you
you've like been proven correct in some way that you could do
this. I don't I don't know how you do it. I legitimately don't
understand. It It boggles the
that he thinks this is cool, that he thinks that he's correct
on this. It's literally only him and some people who have never
updated their opinions ever and have only heard about Israel-Palestine
through him who can sit here nodding along and clapping like
seals. Real true. True real. Yeah. Yeah, it's real. It's true.
It's true. It's real. Yeah. Yeah, you're totally right, Nick.
Let's go, Nick. You got it, Nick.
formed by the guy who went, "Um, what do you think about Palestine?"
to them.
It's a It's I don't know. It's It's It's really stupid. This
whole landscape of like accountability for takes people haven't
even given. It's just really cringe. This is like the the 2023
to 2025 Israel-Palestine
Ethan Klein Hasan [__] discourse is going to be like
Nicholas DeOrio's Gamergate. He will never be able to move on
from it. He is
by that whole drama the same way Brianna Wu is mentally by Gamergate,
okay? It's he will be here forever. He is locked in a prison
here forever for the rest of his life. He will never be able
to leave. He is incapable of moving outside of it, okay?
Streamers are the lowest form of celebrity. Wish more people
would see that. There are many cool streamers. You guys just
enjoy gawking at the
Denims was in Mizkif's DMs. Now all of a sudden she started posting
Emiru hate. What a strange Wow, that seems really reliable. 40
upvote comment on Reddit. Is that really >> coincidence.
And Should we just believe >> It's like, oh, well, why
would Denims be talking to Mizkif? And it's like, oh.
Wait, Mizkif is going after Tech to Oh.
Oh, it's Oh. Oh. Oh, it's all a conspiracy. Wait, where is this
coming from? Denims Denims was in Miz's DMs.
This is not true. Do you want to go through like the providence
of this claim? Like why people are making this claim? Cuz I can
tell you exactly why.
I know exactly why this claim was made. He has it backwards?
I don't think he has it backwards. I don't know if if Denims
and Miz have ever talked. Miz said they've never talked, okay?
So he made this up, but I can go through why this comment was
probably made and how people are trying to paint it cuz it is
very funny to me, but maybe we'll let him do his whole analogy
here real >> people would see that. There are many cool
all of a sudden she started posting Emiru hate. What a strange
coincidence. And it's like, oh, well, why would Denims be talking
to Mizkif? And it's like, oh.
Wait, Mizkif is going after Tech to Look at the post though,
please. Wait, which post? Oh, whoops. Oh.
Oh, it's it's just Game of Thrones again. Yeah, get ready. So
like their stream doesn't even know that they're friends with
me, right? One >> They're they're a small streamer. Their
stream doesn't know that we're friends.
And they were telling me that they're like after some reason
people like always bring up in my chat even though they don't
know that we're like friends. And they said that they were talking
about the Epstein files. Like just being like, "Oh, yeah, that's
like disgusting. It's crazy." Then someone in their chat was
like "Wow, you have more balls than Amouranth to talk about the
Epstein files." Dude, this is the this is what I'm [__]
talking about, bro. Bro, these just ban those people. Just [__]
If someone's "Amouranth's not talking about the Epstein files.
What could this mean?"
Ban all these people. Don't engage with them. They're not human
beings. Throw them out. >> files. And they were like
>> But dude, this is not an isolated incident. This happens
all the time. Just ban these [__] people, dude. I
was like that has to be satire or something. He's like, "That's
WHAT THE [__] ARE THEY TALKING ABOUT?
LIKE what um am I like Dude, they're they're they're Wait, just
ban Is he asking to ban those people in someone else's chat?
Bro, this guy I literally walked away.
I walked to my door. I grabbed a package from outside.
And then I came back in.
And I I'm like doing something else. And I can listen more than
this guy with just his stream going on.
Bro, what is this guy? He just doesn't listen. This is not an
isolated incident. This happens all the time. Just ban these
people, dude. I was like that has to be satire or something.
He's like, "That's impossible."
Do you guys think it's like all of the donations and the soundboards
coming through constantly? Do you think he has it all playing
in his ear and his brain is like slowly being rotted by the absolute
audio pollution that is his stream? That like he can't even pay
attention to the clips. He can't His like attention span is totally
now
Like he's he runs a stream that's basically like a a VLT.
Like I I don't know. He just he can't pay attention. He's not
doing anything.
He's literally losing. He'll be in the middle of covering something.
What was that What was the podcast that was canceled? On a clip
that's about the podcast that got canceled.
Like what the [__] is he doing, man?
What are they talking about?
Like what um am I like Dude, there there is literally there is
nothing on planet Earth that can implicate Emeru in the Epstein
files. There's no way in all hell that she's pro-Jeffrey Epstein.
And somehow this is a perfect example. Yeah, this You know why
I'm not talking about Jeffrey
You know why we didn't do a segment?
Because it would cost me money. Last time I did a Jeffrey Epstein
segment, YouTube took the video down. And I don't care that much.
So I just look at it and laugh on my own time. I will not be
doing a Jeffrey Epstein segment because YouTube gave me a strike.
That's the only reason I'm not talking Does she stream on YouTube?
talking about Epstein. What does that say about YouTube, chat?
So they didn't say anything cuz like they don't even know that
we're friends, but they're like
>> I don't know. Nick is literally the protector. So Dude,
the night to the protector. It's awfully quiet. I mean
That's funny. If you protect the thing called most dear, does
that make you a protector or something else?
Difficult question.
But I need somebody, you know, maybe Tecto could answer this
after reading a little Marcus Aurelius. Maybe, you know, I don't
have the philosophical basis to answer this, but you know.
Yeah, for me personally
for me personally, I'm not sure.
Very sus sussy sussy among us. Uh speaking of Denims, well, she
raided in with 2,700
And this is the graph.
Oh, boy.
the view >> Does Nick not stream on Twitch? Does he not
know that this is how um raids work on Twitch? I Does he think
like when you get raided by a bigger streamer? And Denims isn't
even that big. That you get like tons of subs for that?
I This is very confusing. >> ally you have financially
supported uh stream to literally 20 times your audience, and
then shoves the audience right into your stream, yet 100% of
them decide to leave and not subscribe. I am suspicious that
the one sub was iDubbz trying to Oh my god, dude. The only one
who I actually believe has done this trick is I think that Keemstar
has done it on Lolcal a lot. Ooh, I think is this I miss the
old iDubbz. Is he basically just on the iDubbz snark board right
now? This be like iDubbz snark. I miss the old iDubbz. r/imiss
the old iDubbz. F.
>> You really have to take a critical look at your content
and ask yourself, is the haters or is it me? I'm just glad we
can look at this and and know that the snarkers won. The snarkers
were correct. The snarkers just have won a totally okay. Snarkers
were correct all along. I thought snarking was evil? Well, that
is what he would have had you believe before. Snarking on iDubbz
is justified, okay? Snarking on evil people is justified. It's
just all about whether or not they're good. What is that What
is the phrase? No bad tactics, only bad
Right? Right? That's That's clearly what it is. That's so funny.
Imagine going from 200 viewers to 2,700 viewers, and then back
down to like 200 viewers, and you gain one sub.
What Why? This is fake news Ian is a rising star with amazing
content. You're right. You're I don't know what's happening.
Can you spare a sub? Spare a sub. Spare a sub.